quarante huit heures après le drame qui
a coûté la vie à un jeune homme de 19
ans dans un règlement de comptes à torcy
la peur grandit parmi les habitants du
quartier les faits se sont passés à 50
mètres de la mairie et l'homme poursuivi
et blessés à coups de barres de fer là
était à quelques mètres de l'école
primaire du quartier
madame nettement un petit peu comment
vous vivez justement les événements des
derniers jours
bah un petit peu angoissé quand même par
rapport aux enfants surtout
mais sinon voilà de savoir que les crs
qui sont venus la police est présente
ça nous rassure quand même vu ni rien
mais la seule à bien vouloir nous parler
à visage découvert les autres ont
préféré garder l'anonymat par peur des
représailles sait jamais ce qui peut
arriver
j'ai des collègues ici quand jack ont
déjà posté les trucs sur facebook quand
ils leurs voitures brûlées donc j'ai pas
trop envie que ça m'arrive je ne peux
pas avoir un avenir ici on pense on
pense beaucoup de personnes pensent eux
partir d'ici j'ai grandi dans cette
ville qui était tout le temps sur et on
n'avait pas ces soucis nous je sais
qu'on sortait nos parents il n'avait pas
peur pour nous maintenant à l'âge où nos
enfants ils peuvent sortir comme nous
ils jouent avec leurs copains on se dit
que non on peut pas on peut pas on peut
pas les lâcher ce qu'on a tout le temps
peur ce matin les maires de torcy et du
creusot ont fait une conférence de
presse commune
ils demandent à l'état de respecter sa
mission d'ordre public et de donner plus
de moyens pour oeuvrer à la sécurité des
habitants notamment par un retour de la
police de proximité pas une présence
ponctuelle une présence qui soit la plus
répétée possible même si elle n'est pas
en permanence
cette police de proximité qui a disparu
et qui n'est jamais revenu par exemple
nous en avons besoin et c'est ce que
nous demandons parce que c'est ça qui
permet de garder le lien entre le
citoyen et les policiers donc ceux qui
doivent assurer le lord re les maires
des deux communes ont décidé de lancer
un appel à tous les élus du département
pour une marche solidaire samedi
prochain pour demander plus de présence
policière dans les quartiers la
préfecture de son côté n'a pas répondu à
notre demande d'interview